Luna's honey Allen oh my god
yay you don't seem as excited about no
I'm I'm really excited this is so
surreal after two years of of internet
flirting and bullying gifts which one of
us did which of those things he's here
in Los Angeles and I invited him to my
home one to show off my sweet decor and
to to exploit him for my own video game
there's so many Pro fellows here and
it's possible when you see like a guy
with a really nice car and you're like
that guy's overcompensating for
something it's like seeing a girl with
you know more than 5 throw pillows girls
hide their secrets under throw pillows
it's true
there's a [ __ ] dude fair there's just
an insecurity fairy that comes down and
takes my way my book is coming out soon
and a lot of things in the book deal
with me giving you advice so I feel
really like prime and ready to do more
of that hoodie
I'm professionally an advice giver and
then the good additional term is advice
giver I'm professional advice giver I
rap and I'm good with ladies so that's
the bedroom I went on Twitter and
tweeted for you guys to ask us things
that you need advice on using the
hashtag cast grace hood but in hindsight
it should have been asked goody
that's goodie that was great the way we
trended we trended so so there you go
we're feeling validated so let's make
you feel something
what was that caused our for shoulder oh
thank you tell me actual dirt on my
daughter Brooke honey how do I get
[ __ ] to line
for me offer them snacks it's true
[ __ ] love snacks how do you get
vicious to line up for you I don't think
you want a line isn't like without just
can not one [ __ ] you got a hold down
that one [ __ ] for real though you're
gonna hold down that one [ __ ] and then
learn her actual name and color by your
name instead of [ __ ] yeah and make her
feel special how should I tell New York
boy I find his face attractive i'ma let
you take that
howdy John Muir boy you find his face
attractive just like that why be any
other way than honest and upfront that's
how everyone is in New York whether you
want them to be or not to you people
don't like to talk to each other in New
York so if you go up to someone and like
and like try to talk as you might like
I'm here passing for money I'm gonna
instantly think you're mugging me even
if you're a sweet girl like what you
look like in your phone you look super
sweet but I also feel like this could be
a catfishing photo and you might be some
like Shalaby old man in Minnesota that's
how New York has changed my perspective
on people I trust no one
perfect name for my kittens this isn't
advice this is asking us to name her kid
move I'm assuming the mom already has a
name so the two kids I'm gonna take the
left one and I'm gonna call it Lorca's
Flores
mm-hmm big slow fictional [ __ ] love
damn short that's pretty great for a
little kitten I'm gonna say the right
one Rosie O'Donnell I like that how was
your day
you know nobody asked that anymore how
was your day how was my day my day was a
little stressful I'll be honest a little
stressful but so much better now okay
mother than I finally urinated my day
was great because I get to hang out with
Grace and that's awesome and I don't
know what else I could even ask for in
life this number one okay
so one of your special skills is being
really authentic and genuine make a
10-second rap about Emma Watson I'll be
box you rap okay I'm ready wait wait
wait my watching you unloosen in what
you you dress really cute where'd you
get that that boot Emma Watson believes
in equality for women and men that's so
dumb do you say dumb amazing how do you
make the most of your ecology or should
I work extra study more just relax get
in that library fool get off Twitter
start working stop tweeting us your
[ __ ] whoa whoa this took a turn read a
quick rap about grace one two three go
grace I like it when a CEO face all
these other [ __ ] they be described
it's full we graze it's full we do it on
the daily and we hate fools who hate
grace I hate all my haters I make mashed
potatoes what if you spill your pumpkin
spice latte get another one no I say
celebrate the loss I like a boy in my
class how do I gain confidence to say hi
to him I said just like tweet at them
don't do it in person
no don't get married oh how do I figure
out my true passion in life that's a
really legitimately hard question I know
I don't think other people can answer
this for you do you feel like you sought
out your passion or you just like it was
something that you enjoy doing any
somehow discover that and then you
wanted to feel that creativity yeah and
then mine was a hobby that became a job
I think some people just don't have
passions and that just sucks you
shouldn't try to find one passion find
your passions not the soap opera
that's one this is the last one rights
right what's a good yearbook quote this
is tough because we all know we're only
defined by our high school yearbook
quotes here are some options none of
this matters we're all gonna die someday
I'll forget 70 to 80 percent of you in
two months [ __ ] get money Mo Money mo
problems you peaked at 18 cool you could
do that that's a pretty good one I'm a
chargeable royalty in perpetuity
we did it having so many accomplishments
guys this is Schuyler house
I've been Val yes I'm swallowing regret
right now don't forget to go the whole
album is out now right they can go buy
the whole thing it came out yesterday
the album is out and you can steal it I
would like you to buy it because I don't
want to eat ramen noodles forever buy
her book gone buy albums spend all your
money's on us yeah you're not gonna die
with money in your pocket right you know
very dark yeah I know I don't know what
happened I don't know this is not a
Missy Elliott video